if all men are created equal Coolidge  continues that is final  think of that word final and compare it  to the word restful in the first  sentence of this quote right when you  reach the end you stop if they are  endowed with unalienable rights that is  final if governments derive their just  powers from the consent of the governed  that is final no advance no progress can  be made beyond these propositions if  anyone wishes to deny their truth or  their soundness the only direction in  which he can proceed historically is not  forward but backward toward the time  when there was no equality no rights of  the individual no rule of the people  those who wish to proceed in that  direction cannot lay claim to progress  they are reactionary their ideas are not  more modern but more ancient than those  of the revolutionary fathers